for the girls why do you guys only care  about double standards when they benefit  you  so no because this is a perfect example  right because if he's  right  who even is  to talk about females like that he is no  one he he's no one he's worth over three  years just because he's got money  doesn't mean he's that guy okay simple  respect respecting women having money  okay you guys are you guys are diverting  from the question though because I asked  you I asked you I asked you like like no  no no no so no no this is the point this  is the point you're diverting from the  question because he's saying something  that's been ancient men are trash like  you're you're categorizing a home the  question I asked you was why shouldn't  the female tick-tockers that say men  ain't [ __ ] and men are trash be banned  too because we can because